okay so the topic of this video will be
chromosomes and their mutations so let's
go ahead and get started
okay so when we look at a picture like
this this is called a karyotype it's a
picture of a person's chromosomes and
what we hope to see are the normal
amount of chromosomes which would be 46
total chromosomes 23 pairs of
chromosomes and the reason our
chromosomes come in pairs is because we
inherit 23 chromosomes from our mother
these would be the maternal chromosomes
and then we inherit 23 chromosomes from
our father these would be the paternal
chromosomes now are the chromosomes on
the left always the ones from your
mother and the chromosomes on the right
always from your father and the answer
is no we can't actually tell which
chromosome is maternal and which
chromosome is paternal they are just
randomly arranged however we do receive
23 chromosomes from each parent
and the first of these chromosome
disorders to discuss is a a type of
disorder called non-disjunction and you
might remember a picture like this this
is the process of meiosis so
improper chromosome separation tends to
happen during the process of meiosis
when chromosomes are being pulled to
opposite cells sometimes errors happen
in the formation of the gametes the
gametes being the sperm and males and
the eggs and females
and one of the first types of
non-disjunction to discuss are Trisomy
conditions and this is where the cells
that are created will have three of a
certain type of chromosome for example
in this picture sufferers of down
syndrome also called trisomy 21 have
three chromosome 21s in their cells
we'll try to explain how this happens in
a little bit
another example of a Trisomy disorder is
patau syndrome also called Trisomy 13
where the sufferers have three
chromosome 13s in every one of their
cells
and then finally another example of a
Trisomy disorder would be kleinfelter's
syndrome also called xxy syndrome where
they have three sex chromosomes
and then there's also non-disjunction
disorders called monosomi disorders
where the cells have only one of a
chromosome where they should have two
Turner syndrome right here also called
monosomi X syndrome is a great example
of this where sufferers of this disorder
only possess one of the X chromosomes
so let's try to see how this happens
so let's do a side-by-side comparison on
the left are is a cell that's going to
go through the normal process of meiosis
and so crossing over just occurred where
the chromosomes break off and exchange
segments with one another and then as we
go through meiosis one we get to a stage
called anaphase one where the two
chromosomes separate and then as we go
through meiosis II the two halves of the
chromosomes separate are the chromatids
and notice what you have we have
four cells that have been created and
each cell has one copy of the genetic
material this is very much the normal
process of meiosis here
now on the right hand side
crossing over just occurred and it
recombined the chromosomes that's normal
and let's go through anaphase one of
meiosis normally the chromosomes
separate one chromosome went to the cell
to the left one chromosome to the cell
to the right now highlighted in red is
anaphase II of meiosis II Watch What
Happens Next
notice how in the third cell the entire
chromosome was pulled to the third cell
and so what we have here are the first
two cells are fine they each have one
copy of the genetic material like
they're supposed to but the third cell
has two copies of the genetic material
because two chromatids make up a
chromosome and then on the right cell
this cell has zero copies of the genetic
material well let's follow this a little
more
on the left let's look at the normal
process let's say that these are female
egg cells the gametes well here comes
some male sperm cells and so when the
sperm cells fuse with the egg cells you
might know that they create a diploid
zygote and in this case notice how
diploid zygotes they're supposed to have
two copies of the genetic material
that's normal well let's look at the
other side now
of these four cells only two of them are
normal you have two normal egg cells on
the left and you have two abnormal egg
cells on the right well here comes some
sperm cells normal sperm cells from a
male and when the sperm cells fertilize
the egg cells I hope you see the Dilemma
first of all the two cells on the left
are normal normal diploid zygotes they
have two copies of the genetic material
look at the third cell this is a zygote
with a Trisomy disorder because it has
three copies of the genetic material
look to the cell on the right
oh um I forgot this is uh this might be
uh the condition that leads to an
individual suffering from Down syndrome
or patao syndrome notice three
chromosome 13s there
but now notice the cell to the right
this is a zygote with a monosomi
disorder where they only have one copy
of the genetic material for instance
Turner syndrome all because of an error
in chromosome separations
well what about during anaphase number
one I've highlighted in red watch this
the two chromosomes still experience
crossing over and exchange segments of
of chromosomes with one another that's
normal but as we go into anaphase number
one both chromosomes get pulled to the
left cell that's not supposed to happen
only one chromosome should be in the
left cell and the other chromosome
should be in the right cell
and if we follow this out next as we go
into anaphase two notice what we have
here we have the two cells on the left
have two copies of the genetic material
they're not supposed to these are
supposed to be gametes like egg cells
and sperm cells they're only supposed to
have one copy of the genetic material
the two cells on the right have zero
copies of the genetic material
so if we continue this
and we have four egg cells each of these
are abnormal well here comes some sperm
cells the male gametes and when the
sperm cells fertilize these egg cells
each of them is abnormal for different
reasons the two on the left these two
zygotes would would have a Trisomy
disorder because there's three copies of
the genetic material in those two cells
but the two zygotes on the right would
have a monosomy disorder because they
only have one copy of the genetic
material because the the chromosomes did
not separate properly during meiosis
this is a non-disjunction error
well let's look at a couple other
mutations that can happen along with
chromosomes so crossing over which is
the event during meiosis number one
prophase number one of meiosis one is a
normal event where chromosomes
intertwine with one another homologous
chromosomes are supposed to intertwine
with one another and they exchange
segments of DNA it's a very important
step of meiosis because it it helps to
create the genetic diversity that we see
within our species
however errors can often happen during
this process
and so here's a chromosome
and let's divide this chromosome into
six segments segment A B C D E and F
and so now this colorful object is going
to represent the chromosome and every
segment you know may contain dozens or
hundreds of genes so let's let's show
how crossing over mutations can differ
from one another and how they can happen
so the first type of of mutation would
be a a segment is accidentally deleted
in the crossing over process so watch
the normal chromosome three two one
during crossing over notice what
happened the B segment was deleted and
so this chromosome could be missing
dozens to hundreds of genes that are
incredibly important in the formation of
many proteins within this person
syndrome is a great example of this if
you're curious you can Google this a
little more detail but sufferers of this
disorder are missing a small portion of
chromosome number five
and then there are the duplication
mutations where chromosome segments are
duplicated so watch the normal
chromosome three two one
during crossing over
a segment got duplicated and so here we
have a case where there's uh extra
genetic information
on this chromosome an example is this
syndrome right here I've never really
heard of this syndrome until researching
this slideshow but this one is caused by
sufferers having extra material on
chromosome number 12.
and then there are the inversions that
can happen where chromosome segments the
order of the segments are swapped with
one another so watch the normal
chromosome three two one during crossing
over segments might get swapped with one
another now I've I when I was
researching this presentation turns out
some of these inversions are the suffer
the people who have these inversions
really don't suffer any health effects
but there are some uh that that do so
some cases of this disorder right here
are caused by an inversion of chromosome
number seven so what I read is that not
these inversions are not always
guaranteed to lead to problems but
sometimes they do
and then there are the translocation
disorders where chromosome segments from
an outside chromosome are gained so
watch the normal chromosome during the
swapping of chromosome parts
this might happen where this chromosome
obtained another segment letter labeled
letter G from another chromosome
an example of this disorder is this
blood cancer right here where a portion
of chromosome number nine has actually
attached to chromosome number 22. so
these are examples of mutations that
happen during the act of crossing over
and there you go I hope you found this
short video helpful on some examples of
chromosome mutations thank you for
watching if you're in my class you know
try to solve these questions I'm happy
to check your answers before school or
after school one day thanks for watching